heute testen wir was München
liefertechnisch drauf hat und bestellen
bei den drei besten Restaurants bei dem
man sich Essen liefern lassen kann im
letzten Video waren wir schon bei den
Top foodsports also schauen wir was uns
erwartet alright wir haben die App
geöffnet und ich gehe als allererstes
mal auf die Filter filtere direkt nach
Bewertung und ich hoffe dass es gute
Sachen sind in Berlin war ich ein
bisschen enttäuscht als wir das ganze
gemacht haben aber jetzt haben wir 650
Restaurants die hier zu uns ins Hotel
liefern da sollte was gutes dabei sein
log-markt Churros als allererstes 9,8
bisher kann ja so himmlisch sein finde
ich gut das einzige was ich scheiße
finde ist dass die direkt darunter noch
einen Sweet Spot ist die Zimtschnecken
Fabrik machen jetzt ein süßes Video oder
wie und der dritte Platz ist immer
ich würde fast sagen dass wir nur einen
süßen Spot nehmen nehmen wir lockmacurus
nehmen wir macarine Barbecue Schwabing
und das letzte ist Royal healthy Slices
Leute wir wollten das unbedingt testen
im fußball-video aber es hatte zu so
kommen wir jetzt scheinbar doch noch in
den Genuss aber starten wir ganz oben
stellen uns alle erstes Mal das Dessert
Block mal kennt man ja das sind diese
gefüllten Teigbällchen ich glaube aus
der türkischen Küche ja wir nehmen auf
jeden Fall class ne dann müssen wir
genau wo wir dran sind noch mal Atom mit
Vollmilchschokolade weißer Schokolade
Bitterschokolade Cookie Butterkeks
Pistazien Erdbeeren und blau werden
deine Füllung bueno Füllung Nutella
Füllung Vanille Nutella Füllung okay
Lock mal Atom ich glaube das ist ein
guter ein guter Start in den Tag 11,40 €
wir bestellen und gehen zum nächsten
Restaurant weiter geht's mit dem Korean
Barbecue Schwabing ebenfalls 9,10 was
wirklich zwei top Bewertungen sind ich
glaube wir haben in Köln ein oder zwei
Läden nur die mehr als 9,5 haben haben
auch Menüs Power food Menü groß das
sieht auch so schön farbenfroh aus ich
glaube Unternehmen eins direkt von den
Specials oben weil das sind eh die die
am besten laufen wahrscheinlich machen
wir es uns ganz einfach und nehmen das
powerfood Menü groß 13,19 € statt 16,49
€ haben wir sogar noch einen Schnapper
gemacht zweite Bestellung ist ready und
wir gucken was uns als drittes bestellen
und wir gucken bei Royal healthy Slices
rein das sind georgische Pizzen oder
zumindest so eine Art Pizza was ich noch
nie gegessen noch nie irgendwo gesehen
habe aber was hier in München
scheinbaren echter Geheimtipp ist 9,6
und bisschen schlechter Bewertung als
die anderen aber das hat glaube ich
sogar bei Google 4,9 Sterne aus 1000
Bewertung das muss richtig gut sein
deshalb bleibt auf jeden Fall dran ich
bin sehr gespannt wie das wird ich finde
es krass muss ich sagen dass sie das
hier etablieren konnten weil das Essen
sieht absolut und spektakulär aus auch
was mich hier jetzt wieder anguckt dass
du es auch siehst das ist immer Rudi da
muss ja was auf der Zunge passieren ne
da muss was auf der Zunge passieren ja
auf was gehen jetzt gehen wir auf dem
Peter Burger gehen wir ich glaube
tatsächlich auf den Fotos waren am
häufigsten diese mashquri nehmen wir
einfach mal ganz ehrlich ich würde es
eigentlich nicht bestellen also wenn es
nicht gut bewertet wäre würde ich nie zu
bestellen aber ich glaube das ist ein
richtiger Geheimtipp und wir nehmen noch
einmal weil es mich einfach interessiert
so ein Peter Burger Parma das sieht
wirklich pervers aus rein in den
Warenkorb und wir bestellen ich bin
gespannt wie lange es dauert bis das
erste essen da ist und unsere erste
Bestellung ist da von Mama Barbecue
Express schauen wir rein was es gibt
sehr kompakt sehr schwer also wenn man
das in der Hand hat ordentlich oben
haben wir einmal ich weiß es gar nicht
mehr das sind wahrscheinlich diese
dumplings wieder dabei waren wow die
sind richtig gut aus sind auch noch ein
bisschen crispy nicht schlecht jetzt
nicht gedacht und hier hot gogi Barbecue
classic das sieht schon echt gut aus
wirklich viele erkennen kann man hier
jetzt noch nicht oder kann man nicht
aber man erkennt dass es unbekannt ist
also sowas kann ich auf jeden Fall in
Köln schon mal nicht bestellen das feier
ich und gerade wenn ich in einer anderen
Stadt bin dann will ich gerne sowas
Neues probieren oben drauf Sesam so eine
rote Soße ich denke mal das ist die die
für den Spice verantwortlich ist eine
Seite haben wir ein bisschen kostler und
gebetet ist das ganze auf so einem
Klebereis den ich erstmal probieren will
weil ich glaube das ist so genau dieser
geile klebrige Reis den man liebt
[Musik]
wow
and powerfood ich glaube auch dass das
powerfood ist mit dem Reisbett und ein
bisschen chickendorf noch so ein paar
Gemüse als Zeit ist richtig geil ich
probiere jetzt mal mit Bulgari ich
glaube es könnte scharf werden
wirklich was ganz eigenes for real ein
richtig gutes Essen ist das eine Stunde
bevor du ins Schwimmen gehst du hast
Kraft glaube ich aber richtig Kraft
geile Schärfe das Fleisch umgebaut ist
so auch sehr sehr weich sehr zart aber
trotzdem so eine besondere Textur das
ist ein richtig geiles Mehl also vor
real mit diesen Mandu mit einem Getränk
was wir bekommen haben für 13,49 €
übertrieben gut würde ich wirklich
jederzeit bestellen wenn ich in Köln
wäre probier mal die
manduard zu Recht unter den topspots
geiles lieferkonzept ausgefallenes essen
kein Standard das will ich auch in Köln
haben weiter geht's mit einer kleinen
süßen Pause wir haben hier drin unsere
lockmaß 11,40 € für dieses atomlock Mal
weil München Preise 11,40 € Alter und
hier in der Mitte haben wir direkt so
einen locker also ein gefülltes
teig-bällchen das wirklich kaum noch zu
erkennen ist unter Pistazien crumble
Schokosoße wirklich von allem was dabei
der erste Lock mal den ich in meinem
Leben esse ich probiere das einfach mal
also ganz ehrlich ich glaube das ist
somit das substanzloseste was man essen
kann du hast eine knusprige Panade innen
drin flüssigen Kern aus Nutella
vorstellen das verklebt dir so komplett
den Rache im Nutella ist ja eh so wenn
du so ein bisschen Nutella so vom Löffel
ist dann klebt so dein Mund und hier
hast du halt mehrere Löffel Nutella mit
jedem Bissen ich würde es mir halt
wahrscheinlich ohne dieses Video nicht
bestellen aber wer gerne süß ist für den
ist das richtig geil das war ein
bisschen Bitterschokolade dabei also es
ist nicht nur süß aber das ist einfach
eine perverse Kreation so frittiert hat
Teig mit zuckerfüllung wenn man liebt
liebt man es für mich ist es nicht meine
Nummer eins weiß einfach nicht so gerne
mag aber jetzt kommt das auf das hier am
meisten gespannt bin wir erwarten gerade
noch die Lieferung Georgien happy Slices
und ich glaube das wird besonders und
auch die letzte Bestellung ist da wir
gucken mal rein das hier sind die
georgischen Pizzen und es hat wirklich
ein bisschen gedauert bis sie angekommen
sind das ist aber nicht die Schuld vom
Laden ultranet der Besitzer hat mich
persönlich angerufen meinte es kann
nicht sein die sind schon so lange
unterwegs kam schon zu spät ich habe
extra noch mal frische gebacken für dich
damit die auch warm ankommt deshalb das
lassen wir außen vorbei der Bewertung
als sie ein bisschen kühl sind die sind
aber sogar noch warm also es ist gar
nicht so schlimm aber der Laden gibt
sich wirklich Mühe und wir nehmen uns
direkt mal hier diese georgische Pizza
wirklich so schwer dieser Apparat hier
sieht aus wie so ein ausgehöhltes
Brötchen irgendwie so ein bisschen
probieren einfach mal keine Ahnung was
mich erwartet
das ist glaube ich das saftigste was ich
seit langem gegessen habe es ist so
Sancy und du musst es probieren weil ich
glaube dann denkst du ganz anders
darüber nach okay ja fütter mich wieder
immer so richtig rein so ein Männer bist
ist so saftig Alter und es schmeckt
wirklich übelst gut ne man checkt gar
nicht wie das schmeckt also wirklich das
unfotogenste Essen dass ich seit langem
gesehen habe weil es schmeckt so brutal
dafür wie es aussieht
das kann man auch nicht schön essen
aber ich feier das München auch in der
Hinsicht so experimentierfreudig ist und
dass solche außergewöhnlichen Spots
unter den Top 3 sind weil sie ja nichts
davon ist ja so Pizza Burger sonst was
gewesen ne müssen wir auch mal sehen das
schmeckt wirklich brutal gut 8,50 €
super fair davon kannst Du glaube ich
eine kleine Familie sagt bekommen auch
wenn das nur so groß ist ich gehe mal
hier in diesem Peter Burger rein der
kostet 12 € 50 das ist voll real
eigentlich guck mal das sieht aus wie so
ein bisschen dazwischen haben wir so
einen frischen Belag kam etwas Rucola
getrocknete Tomaten es könnte auch schon
italienisch sein wieder ne
ich probiere
durch die Lieferzeit jetzt ein bisschen
kau intensiv geworden aber geile Zutaten
man schmeckt so den leckeren
parmaschinen das ist nicht irgendwas
billiges geiler Laden geiler Spot sehe
ich mich auf jeden Fall noch mal
bestellen ist vielleicht auch nichts für
jeden Tag aber auf jeden Fall hat das
mit daseinsberichtigung das war dann
wohl die drei besten Restaurants die
hier zu mir ins Hotel in München
geliefert haben ganz ehrlich München hat
was drauf das habe ich auch schon mal
den Top foodsports gemerkt das merke ich
bei den liefer Restaurants auch einfach
schön München ist auch wunderschön
vielleicht sieht man mich bald wieder
ihr könnt ja mal in die Kommentare
schreiben ob ihr Lust hättet noch
weitere Videos aus München wir sehen uns
demnächst wieder aus Köln bis dahin
mach's gut ciao ciao eine Sache werde
ich mit diesem Auto nach dem heutigen
Video gemeinsam haben ICE jetzt können
wir die Reaktion von Kämpfen einblenden
ich werde eine Sache mit einem Auto
gemeinsam haben nach dem Stream heute
wieder abbrechen
[Musik]